welcome everybody to today's episode of
the h3 podcast
i'll be totally frank with you this is
one that i've not been looking forward
to
i've in fact been dreading having this
person back on
oliver tree last time we had him on he
broke he first of all he tried to take
me on a vape off
lost tragically then because he was so
angry
he broke he started trashing our our
studio
he broke our our talking beanie and then
like he
went through this crazy rage and broke
he brought in his own big vape
pen and he broke it and it was just
i don't know i didn't really like the
guy but um
[Music]
basically his producer called our
producer
and both of those names is dan which is
weird so they have like a weird
camaraderie
because both their names is dan and dan
our dan
has been begging us like you gotta do
them a favor
he's got this new album coming out
called ugly's beautiful
comes out july the 17th which it's
already out
i didn't get i did see you're not
supposed to start talking yet
just do you can you can somebody turn
his mic off i'll be me
can somebody turn his mic off please
until i'm ready
so anyway his album
his album's out it's called ugly's
beautiful it's getting really
horrible reviews by me anyway i haven't
read any of the real reviews but i heard
it and i didn't like it at all
so i was like why am i going to bring
him on and promote this trash album
called uglies beautiful out july 17th
which is
yesterday and but dan was like please
you
uh please do me this favor so i'm doing
this for dan in honor of their
relationship with the other dan
anyway also today's episode is sponsored
by candidco
me undies and tushy who we love and
cherish
so with that being said oliver tree a
musician artist entertainer
uh anger management anger problems
poor vapor uh you can you can enter now
oliver tree
may enter the frame and speak to us
and and protest as well
oliver's just flipped he's rolled in and
he's flipped this off
why are you first of all see i feel like
everything he does
is just dude he's trying to show me up
but he's not good like he knows that i
have the gatsby
right you know about the gatsby right
because he's rolled up in some ghetto
like gold spray-painted mobility scooter
and he's trying to show me up
he's just flipping me off oliver what is
are you injured though for real what's
going on i don't know if you're paying
attention to anything in the news man
but
yesterday i rode the world's biggest
scooter a half mile
and i broke the world [ __ ] record and
a lot of people are talking about it
and i don't know if you watched but
there was an actual accident that
happened at the finish line
where a gust of wind actually knocked me
over
i actually broke my radius bone and my
hand
broke multiple bones in my ankle here
you can see this i got a couple
abrasions rooms nothing too major i've
definitely had much more gnarly crashes
but
it was kind of a bittersweet kind of
thing where i actually was able to make
it the length of the course but
are you staying on are you done yeah no
it's on i just wasn't oh my god
this guy is a walking calamity just let
me know when you're done we can actually
have an interview or something i don't
know what
bro did you get a concussions or
something like did you get brain damage
there was a brief moment where i was out
i was seeing stars and there was
actually a moment where i
left my body i was looking over myself
and that was pretty [ __ ] surreal did
you see a doctor
i think you might have brain injuries i
spent the night in the hospital i got
out at 6 00 a.m this [ __ ] morning i
barely slept two hours so
i'm a bit off today but okay that makes
sense yeah if we have to do this thing
now let's [ __ ] do it
so tell me about the uh giant world
record i mean if you
crash is it still a world record right
well technically i did make it to the
finish line but the wind
knocked me over while i was hitting the
line and it just
was there a record keeper there from
guinness yeah we had guinness we had
this guy randy rigatoni from guinness
world book of records who was there
representing them
and we had all the legit specs
everything was filled out and then i was
able to make it
roughly a half mile down this landing
strip and it was a pretty [ __ ] crazy
ass moment i don't know if you watched
it it sounds like it didn't
no can i watch it come do you have the
video yeah it's on youtube we live
streamed it yesterday and now it's
available for the world to see
to tell you the truth it was pretty
[ __ ] up that the whole thing got
completely ruined
the scooter's pretty damaged right now
but i do have a new dream
i'm looking to drive this thing across
america trying to take it state to state
and eventually trying to take this thing
global so i am looking for investors
if anybody wants to throw down on this
private investors major companies
we're looking for any kind of funding
but we're trying to take the world's
biggest scooter
across america okay and what
and so if i'm investing is what what is
my like
you know what am i investing in exactly
am i is there
all kinds of [ __ ] man we can get into
that later but essentially we'll throw
your logo in there
say oh i see you we'll give you a you
want a sponsor
and how fast does so how approximately
how fast would it take you to get
cross-country in that thing
how long would it take anywhere from a
month to two months
i think at this point it depends on if
i'm able to install the motor in it or
not
because that could cut a lot of time out
it is pretty heavy it's about 600 pounds
so
so to move it on my own it takes a lot
of energy and to be frank with you
you know i can only ride it for about
three hours a day before i start to
collapse
uh okay sounds like a good plan but
you may need like a year so yeah i don't
think
i think two months is optimistic in that
case but
um oliver your album is out ugly is
beautiful now
it's called why is it called ugly is
beautiful is it because you're ugly and
you feel like you wish that you oh that
you were
beautiful i heard all that [ __ ] you were
talking you [ __ ] talking about the
[ __ ] beanie and all this [ __ ] you
didn't even know how to [ __ ] turn the
beanie on
and now you're calling me out in the
middle of a [ __ ] interview it's
supposed to be a [ __ ] puff piece dude
dude of course i knew how to turn it i
you say that it's not a pun who said
it's a punk piece [ __ ] interview
who told you this was a puff piece what
who told you this was a puff piece i
think what they meant to say was
it's a snuff piece ooh
you know what a snuff film is
no well don't you want to explain it to
me don't google it because it's
very disgusting do you know what a snuff
film is
no hey can we wrap this thing up it's
it's not buried
up yeah real questions or what a snuff
film
it's like it's a it's a porn where they
kill you at the end
that's what a snuff film is but i don't
know why so many people know what that
is because it's just so bizarre
i think there was a movie about it
oliver and i didn't know about it so
dan you know what a snuff film is right
yeah i don't think it has to be
uh pornographic necessarily but it's
like
a film where somebody's actually being
hurt
or killed in it there was a movie about
it what was it called
uh we should talk about that film and
less about oliver
hey can we wrap this [ __ ] thing up
man how long are you going to do this
one for
so let me wait wait let me uh break in
here real quick
um oliver's uh love
is a little too hot when he's yelling
it's getting really distorted
i don't know if um ryan wants to come in
and adjust the
gain on it a little bit so do your do
you have tech guys to know what they're
doing there oliver or did you set that
up yourself
i set all this [ __ ] up myself yeah do
everything myself
now i can barely hear you i'm gonna hear
you oliver yeah maybe
split the difference it's quite it's
super quiet bro
it's really i mean you're not even
talking so how can i tell how loud you
are
you have to talk to do a sound check
oliver
hello yeah i can hear you now hear me
dan how does that sound
uh i think that sounds better it was
really just when he started can you yell
that it became an issue yeah can you
yell
something oliver what the [ __ ] dude are
you [ __ ] joking all right
profanity that's going on youtube if you
if you curse like that
then this whole video is going to get
demonetized
so don't video you're never going to see
the [ __ ] light of date man
how are the sound levels it is better
okay oliver come back let's just finish
this look both of us don't want to be
here
so why did you call your album ugly is
beautiful
ugly is beautiful is about learning to
love yourself
it's about learning to find the beauty
and those imperfections and those things
that you have
trouble learning to accept about
yourself and the truth is those are the
things that built the character
and those are the things that made you
who you are so you know it's about
on a surface level being able to accept
yourself and love yourself and
ultimately
learn how to accept where you are in
life because the thing is
you know we always are constantly
wanting more it's never enough and this
is constant game where we're constantly
asking how can we have more how can we
have more and at this point
you need to learn to accept where you're
at and ugly as beautiful is about
arriving to a place of acceptance where
you can accept
not only the way you look and the way
you feel and who you are
but additionally where you are in this
world at this time and just accept this
is it
okay we're wrapping it up after that i
did have a follow-up question
uh oliver rode his scooter off can we
get you out of that scooter i feel like
it's giving a huge obstacle to this
interview
i feel like you've got all the power
with that scooter and i'm just
stationary like i've i wish that i had
my gatsby and i was able to write off
screen too
oliver yeah well you should have brought
it
so oliver let me ask you you say that
it's about accepting what you have
i know you you've you've gained some
thought holy [ __ ] oliver just crashed
into
uh some kind of furniture oliver
do you say that because you have
achieved um
a lot of success i think in the
underground kind of
indie music or you're not really indie
are you you're kind of owned by the man
first of all i'm definitely not an indie
underground artist i'm mainstream
yeah this album is a mainstream album
okay okay ultimately if you ask me
the fact is my life has been nothing but
failure after failure
i signed a record deal when i was 18
years old
here we are nine years later i haven't
even put one album out i've made
15 albums at least upwards of 15 albums
i've made countless
endless [ __ ] singles the truth is i'm
[ __ ] done
wait sorry what are we talking about
oliver do you do you consider the
haircut being one of the failures
my haircut is what has made me who i am
okay
are you wearing a wig or is that your
hair
this is my hair should prove it let me
see your hairline
prove it pull it back pull it back [ __ ]
can you say the p one i don't know but
you so are but but seriously on a
serious note
as a as a somewhat successful musician
i'll say
like do you feel like you find yourself
wanting more success but you're just
kind of excited you said it all in the
[ __ ] question dude
my project has been ultimately a failure
to this point like
everything i've tried to do has always
just missed the [ __ ] bar has just
missed the marker my entire life has
been
one failure after another and the truth
is life is about failure success is
about failure those failures are what we
pick ourselves
up and we keep going and if you don't do
the same thing again then it's not a
mistake it's a learning experience
i believe that very very thoroughly and
so the truth is i
have been chasing my whole life trying
to get to where i want and i will never
be there it will never be enough so i'm
at this point or i have to just accept
this is it this is where i am you got to
just enjoy it this is the [ __ ] golden
days in a couple years i'm going to be
looking back being like what happened
man i [ __ ] let myself go
i mean this is if you think about it
this is probably the peak of your career
right now being on the show with us
this is the [ __ ] lowest point i have
ever hit in my entire life
really even that scooter crash
everything you've been through
you know the scooter crash was fun
compared to this [ __ ] dude
i don't know what i'm doing wrong i'm
trying to hold up conversation but how
am i supposed to have a conversation
with somebody who's not even in frame
oliver
stop driving the [ __ ] scooter bro
don't you have handlers
what's happening do you have handlers
where's dan
can you just play with a fidget spinner
and stop moving
just turn off the motor please i can't
conduct an interview
thank you
now oliver your album has been canceled
how many times like seven times
it's been cancelled eight or nine times
at this point so what
so like once or twice i feel like i can
forgive and
call it a coin like just bad luck but
after seven eight nine times i have a
feeling that
there's some kind of shenanigans going
on like why do you
continue to to have these false starts
why do you keep cancer
i think i wanted the [ __ ] album to
come out three years after i signed with
the label
the label is the one not letting me
release this [ __ ] you think i wanted to
put out eps
that's the equivalent of taking your
[ __ ] book and having someone pull out
a chapter and say oh
well this one will do we can put that
one out now and maybe we'll put a
chapter here
only reason i did any of those [ __ ]
eps was so that i could get budgets to
make music videos
the whole thing is you have to give and
take a little bit and without these
[ __ ] things
if i didn't agree to do the ep there
would be no music videos i would never
have the major budgets that i was able
to get
but it comes at a cost i had to give
bits of my body of work that i've been
working on for five [ __ ] years
had to give that up ultimately this is
something that has been a long time
coming
and through the process i have become so
[ __ ] jaded working in the industry
that this is my last album so ultimately
let me just say this one more time okay
let me cut you off
ultimately this is my last [ __ ] album
i'm ever dropping as oliver tree i'm
done with this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] rip the [ __ ] record label
can go [ __ ] themselves
the [ __ ] radio departments who just
keep vampiring me and keep asking for
more and more [ __ ] they can go [ __ ]
themselves
all the [ __ ] fans who i dedicate my
life to to giving them art and they talk
[ __ ] about me
they can go [ __ ] themselves i'm done
with this [ __ ] i don't need it anymore i
put my whole life into it
and all i've gotten is [ __ ]
disrespect don't drive off dude please
don't drive off just wait
dude i have i have some follow-up
there's a lot of follow-up questions but
you're in
you're are you sure about this
okay am i sure about what this is your
last album
yes i'm [ __ ] sure let me paint it for
you very [ __ ] clearly
i spend 90 of my time promoting this
music
i am artist i've spent my entire life
making art and now that i'm in this
possible
spot and now that i'm in the spot where
i'm making commercially viable music
there's a lot of stresses and pressures
that are put on to making sure that the
music
makes back a fraction of the money
that's being spent going into it
so there's all this need to promote and
promote and promote and when do i get
time to make [ __ ] music
i'm here spending my days with [ __ ]
bastards like you ethan
wasting my days away while i could be
making songs making movies making art
and it's just
i'm so [ __ ] sick of this [ __ ] i want
to go back to being an artist making art
not just being a promotion
sucker i just sold my soul for this [ __ ]
and i'm so [ __ ] done
so i want to make movies i want to do a
lot of other things
i got to make the greatest album i could
make arguably one of the greatest rock
albums of my generation
and that's that i'm gonna leave it at
that and the truth is all music snobs
say this oh i like the earlier stuff i
like the earlier stuff well guess what
you can have the earlier stuff because
that's it i'm going out on a [ __ ]
high note
why is it that the record label does not
want you to release your album that
doesn't make sense okay let me make this
very simple
when i was releasing music at the start
i had maybe five to ten thousand
followers
i talked to the label i had a full album
made and i said hey
what do you guys think can we drop this
and then they said
well the truth is oliver you're not
going to drop an album until you have a
million followers otherwise it's not
going to count as an album
and i said this a million followers and
i can put out an album and they said
a million followers and you can put out
an album
and i [ __ ] two years later i get a
million followers and i go to the label
and i'm like all right we've reached the
[ __ ] point
aren't we ready to put an album out yet
and guess what they [ __ ] told me
why don't you tell me i don't want to
guess
you need to have two million followers
before you drop an album
they literally told me that that why
would they sign you though if what the
expectation they
sign you because they see the potential
but the thing is to make these albums
cost multiple millions of dollars so for
them to get their return on investment
they have to make a product that is
going to be actually
have an audience behind it and if you
don't have at least a couple million
followers there is no real audience
behind it that is the theory that they
have
and that is their entire game they play
and i am [ __ ] sick of playing the
game i'm done
do you think that kovid 19 was possibly
a conspiracy
to prevent your album from releasing on
time
no did the record album start covered
well
because kovid i think delayed
your previous album release right
that's true yeah that was one of the
reasons but ultimately you know
the world got shut down you couldn't do
any productions you couldn't do anything
it was like what
you're gonna release the album without
the whole world built around it
and so is it true that you lost 150 000
followers on instagram
when you announced again that you
delayed it was within the first
two or three days or the first two days
that's gotta hurt i mean that's gotta
hurt
because you know what [ __ ] them right
i want the real fans i'm done with the
[ __ ] fake fans man they're there
they're like oh we're fans you barely
heard what you know name of a song or
two
you know any lyrics bud these people are
[ __ ] fake
so you said that the people are talking
[ __ ] about you what kind of stuff do
they say
everything under the sun man i've
received everything from death threats
to people who want to make my life
miserable i have people who stalk my
[ __ ] parents
it's a [ __ ] way to live yes i have
people who are reaching out to my
parents as people who are old friends of
me
and trying to get my number that way and
it's [ __ ] up man there's some really
[ __ ] up people out there who have no
boundaries
um that's true actually that is actually
true
and you just have experienced it tell me
about it i want to hear about yours
no i agree people don't have boundaries
it's just it's strange that people don't
understand
that they shouldn't do those things you
know sometimes people come to our house
and uh they just they don't somehow
don't realize what they're doing is
super creepy and
weird and wrong but when i call
when i like i've been calling your
parents for example trying to get your
cell number
but because we've met before
obviously it's not a big deal and i and
i also had a few other people like
because your parents blocked my number
so i i recruited some people on
craigslist but they're
contacting them through me so i know
it's fine but some people just don't get
it
right that was you
no well no it was through by proc are
you telling me you're the [ __ ] guy
who's getting my [ __ ] phone number
from my parents
by proxy yeah i have people do it it's
not me directly because they blocked my
number already all right dude let's wrap
this [ __ ] interview up
is there any questions yeah
um when's the last time you washed that
jacket
okay dude [ __ ] you i'm so done with this
[ __ ]
when's the last time you washed those
jeans bro
we hacked low on battery it just turned
off
so but that was us you can't live what's
it like being a touring artist during
covid because now
i feel like that's a big source of of
revenue right it's touring
do you think that's the only way artists
make money yeah so i don't know
it's got to be it's kind of got to be
tough time
revenue-wise right i mean ultimately
that's why i'm leaving the music
industry
not only have i been so jaded by my
experiences and the way that they make
me feel like [ __ ] and that it's never
going to be enough but ultimately
there's no money in this [ __ ] and there
was a while where i went to
there was a while where i went to
business school in san francisco state
and i studied business and i know
business like the back of my hand but
the thing is
when you look at the the actual
structure for the music industry
the bubble has bursted
what do you mean the bubbles bursted
it's over man
but like well i guess you mean because
you can't tour anymore which was pretty
much the only way
or we're doing press interviews through
a [ __ ] zoom dude yeah that's pretty
sad
i have to say i'm i we had a really epic
plan for our podcast
in studio but the cove has been getting
so crazy we kind of i just
i had to call it off and frankly like
i've been wat and i think i made the
right decision because
i've been watching you guys set up back
there nobody's wearing masks you guys
are all breathing down each other's
throats
and so i am confident i made the right
decision ultimately but i
am sad that because we were going to do
a scooter race man we were going to
buddy up on the world's biggest scooter
we were going to i was basically we were
going to have like a mma style
pen or uh like throw down we were going
to do some brazilian jiu jitsu as well
dude i'm just [ __ ] happy i don't have
to be in the same room as you two
suckers
do you think you have kovid honestly at
this point i have no idea i am sweating
like a pig right now
you are let me see your hairline you can
see
oh yeah it is real so why didn't you
show it to me before
cool ethan i do what i want when i want
not when i have people asking me for
[ __ ] favors dude i owe you nothing
i feel like i just [ __ ] a little bit
seeing his hairline like it's like
seeing a girl's thigh
you know back in the day when like
that's gross well no because it's hot
because you don't usually see that so i
got a little turned on
but you know how like in some cultures
like they go oh the elbow don't show the
elbow or it's whatever is covered and
they don't let you see
that's what turns people on so oliver
lifting his hairline
i definitely got chubbed up a little bit
yeah i don't know if we can use that
part man well it's not really up to you
is it
right i mean it's not really up to you
i'll talk to dan i know your guy
um so you're broke you have no fans
i'm just recapping you have no income
generally speaking people have people
don't like you as much as they used to
your record label is sick dude how old
are you what are you a 50 year old
youtuber
let's keep the [ __ ] comments down to
a minimum i'm just recapping what we've
learned i'm trying to recap our
interview thus far so like
you know so but correct me where i'm
wrong be honest with you i came here
trying to be in a good mood i just had a
[ __ ] up night i'm all [ __ ] up i was
in the hospital got out at six
[ __ ] am i show up still to your [ __ ]
ass interview and the truth is man
i brought [ __ ] gifts i thought i was
gonna be a nice guy coming out here
giving gifts to everybody
but meanwhile i come out here and you're
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] before i'm not
talking [ __ ] i'm literally just
recapping what we learned
i was trying to regain the ground we
covered
you correct me where i'm wrong okay so
you brought gifts i mean that is really
nice
i don't know if i want to give him any
more well you have to give it a gift as
a gift
yeah you can well technically it would
be if i was in the same room but since
you guys canceled that portion of the
interview
maybe i can keep all my gifts maybe
that's not such a big deal
that would just be weird you want to
keep the gifts you bought us
i don't know they're pretty good gifts
maybe i do
all right listen oliver not to this is
we have to take a break
and then we'll do the gifts when we come
back is that okay
that's not okay man i'm about to leave
just don't leave because i do want the
kids
i want the gifts uh yeah bro is this
like i don't understand is this an
interview or like aren't we supposed to
talk about [ __ ]
like you got to let me ask you something
we'll get into that
later ethan what is this it's just like
some kind of you have to ask some
[ __ ] questions i don't know if you
ever
every time i try asking questions you
roll your ass off screen
you haven't asked me one decent question
this whole [ __ ] hour or two how long
have we been here
30 minutes do you have a chair in the
where you are
no i don't know you can obviously walk
too like what is this [ __ ] i can
literally leave this here like this
could be my standoff position for the
remainder
well i can i mean is this a good
distance for you guys yeah
or do you want me further back no this
is good not further
cool closer all right let's just go to
break and then we'll we'll
there we go something like that maybe
yeah that's good that'll be my go-to
spot for the remainder of the interview
that sounds great sorry about moving so
much
thank you for saying that i was getting
nervous
yeah i understand it's stressful
thank you to me undies for sponsoring
this
episode of the h3 podcast
it also works as a scarf if you're
really dedicated
but you no need to do that because let
me tell you about me undies
this is the most comfortable underwear
in the game
you're gonna feel like your dick and
balls is taking a magic carpet ride
and aladdin is serenading you
um that's it i mean what else do you
need to know microfibers micro modal
they don't use cotton cotton is for a
plebian scumbag
like their balls and dick to sweat like
the gan
like the genji's the genji's dan
mountain range the ganges i believe it's
a uh
some kind of geographical location where
i imagine it's very sweaty and
uncomfortable
this for example is perfect beautiful
weather
every time every time now listen up
you don't want an empty underwear drawer
i'll be honest with you
that's happened to me in my life way too
many times mostly before i knew ela
and there's look sometimes you want to
free ball
but other times you're forced into it
and let's be honest that's not a good
position to be into
because well now with me on these
ownerships you can eradicate that
terribleness forever
mandu's membership is a monthly
subscription that says new pairs right
to your door
so you can keep your underwear drawer
stocked fresh
and fun plus with membership access
site-wide savings and exclusive sales
you can easily and affordably build a
quality collection of super soft undies
over time
and that's one heck of an upgrade if you
ask me and that's true
the difference between this i don't know
where you get your underwear dan but i
get my [ __ ]
like for before me undues i used to get
it from like
in a pack of like five you know and they
all look the same and that should just
chafe boy a ride that does all the
things you don't want
this solves everything i mean
it's like it's a game changer it's crazy
uh they've got matching pairs if you
want to be cute with your spouse
you can wear the exact same print sick
me on these range
in sizes from extra small to 4xl
beautiful and uh for my listeners they
get a 15
off plus plus free shipping and this is
a no-brainer because
it's a 100 satisfaction guarantee that
means if you don't love the underwear
completely and utterly you send it back
they sniff it once they promise they'll
only sniff it once
then they burn it and you get a full
refund it's that simple it's really a
no-brainer you try these on
if it's not the beautiful most gracious
softest underwear that ever grace your
[ __ ] dick and balls
they'll fully refund you so to get 15
off your first order
free shipping at 100 satisfaction
guarantee go to meundies.com
h3 that's me undies dot com slash
h3 i
love bidets and i am
happy to share the magic of the days
with you via
toshi listen to this you poop you wash
you dry
it's a three-step process tushy is in
the business
of ass blasting with water it's
basically getting a rim job
a sloppy but clean rim job every time
you poop
and everyone has an ass and everyone
deserves the gift of tushy
what is tushy tushy is a sleek bidet
attachment that clips onto your existing
toilet and sprays
your butt completely clean with fresh
water that's why it's called tushy
and it's the best thing you can do for
your butt tissue sprays directly
at your ass it removes the poop
completely so you aren't sitting on
bacteria that leads to nasty things like
hemorrhoids
yeast infections uti's itchy [ __ ] and
skid marks my god
days are common in the rest of the world
so why is an american caught up why are
we still smearing
[ __ ] all over our [ __ ] with toilet
paper we could be squirting water at our
[ __ ] and
getting it clean that way but they saves
you money on toilet paper
which as we've debated at long lengths
is
very expensive toilet paper it will not
clog your toilet
tushy sprays your ass with fresh water
it's not toilet water
tissue connects to the water supply
behind your toilet to spray your dirty
parts clean with fresh water
it's the same water you brush your teeth
with wet wipes are worse for the
environment and worse for the gutters
they're terrible
so why would you use that and when they
call they also cause
anal fissures
but you do not want any part of an anal
fissure that's why
tushie is such a big deal and it's only
75 it's only 79
they've also got the tushy ottoman which
helps you get everything out it's a
little stool you put your feet up it
helps the poop
come out of your butt god bless so go to
hellotushy.com
h3h3 and get 10 off your order
i promise you this is one purchase in
your life you will not regret
let's face it guys there hasn't been
much to smile about recently but when we
get out of this i want you to face the
world
with the biggest most beautiful smile
you can
and that's where candid can help candid
clear
alignment are comfortable removable and
totally invisible
unlike wire braces you can transform
your smile without anyone noticing
plus your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an
expert in tooth tooth movement
candidate only works with orthodontists
never general dentists like other
companies
and with some of those companies you may
never hear from a doctor when you go
through treatment
that is ridiculous and unacceptable with
candid
your treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know
and that's what makes candid so special
the average candid treatment is just six
months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and the cost is on average 50
percent
less than with invisalign so are you
ready to take the first step towards
getting your dream smile
you can't wait to show off get ready
today from the comfort of your own home
with candids risk free starter kit
and 75 dollars off go to candid co
dot com slash h3 and use code h3 that's
candid co
candid c o dot com slash h3
code h3 for your risk free starter kit
and 75 off
candid co dot com slash h3 code h3 baby
let's get that beautiful smile on your
face
did you see that sick
glass flip down sick we're back with
oliver
which can only be described as probably
the worst most
uninteresting interview we've done very
combative
not friendly i will say just because we
have him on that his new album is
out now called ugly is beautiful it's
about his struggles to
uh accept his you know subpar looks
comes out um well it's already out stop
dude it's already out
are you doing i'm gonna are you gonna
support me you're gonna talk [ __ ] about
me dude make your [ __ ] mind
i mean no i'm supporting you i have how
many tracks on the album
i don't know man i sent it to you two
weeks ago did you listen
i listened yeah i don't sure album how
many tracks are on it
14 dude 14 and you've been working on it
for how long
five years some of these songs are even
older do the math bro
on that do the math what is that like
one year per se
man greatest album you've ever heard man
it is it you know what i'm going to drop
the shtick
right now for a minute i think it's a
great say that you can't say that dude
i'm just want to speak from the heart
for a minute
i think the album's great and i think
you did a great job and you should feel
really proud of it
and i hope everyone goes and streams it
thank you
now do you have gifts for us
you want to do that yeah man i do have
gifts and after what you just said
i feel right about bringing them out
okay bring them out
um first things first i want to give a
gift to my godson theodore
uh can you bring that out not that one
the other one did we name him godfather
yeah
last time oh we did for theodore
i got him his first razor scooter
wow that's super nice and this is
actually the same model that i use
and it's just a classic red scooter this
was my first scooter
and i want it to be his first scooter
and the way i see it is you can never
really start him too young
thank you man and yeah also for when he
does nighttime rides bring this one out
so this is maybe when he's a little
older but when he's going out for night
time rides i got him
oh this piece it's glow-in-the-dark
wheels and then it actually has a
wheelie bar
and underneath that it shoots out sparks
so if you do let him do this anytime
soon make sure you
actually shoot sparks bro that's sick
i said to actually shoot sparks yes it
does
it does shoot out sparks but just make
sure he's not wearing flammable shoes
oh flammable shoes got it okay
okay and um you know after everything
said and done i want to say this
all beef aside i want to throw it out
the window i want to apologize
for taking your guys stuff and messing
with it and i want to give a gift
this is also for my godson but it's also
a gift to the parents as well in the
sense of
you know you get to see him wear it and
uh bring it out
oh my god oh wow
so this is a 30 stack that i had
constructed for theodore i had the idea
in a dream
and this is something that i think you
know he could probably wear
out and about when you guys take him and
um i think it would look very good on
him
and you know you can't keep the doll i
was that's actually nice
if we could you can have the stack so
is there some kind of structural
structure
bearing like pull inside the beanies no
it's literally just beanies stacked on
top of each other it took me about two
weeks
wow how are they attached okay okay
thank you
with just paper clips okay thank you
very much
paper clips theodore's cleaning up
yeah and um and next up i want to say
gila i am such a big fan of what you're
doing with teddy fresh i'm so inspired
by what you're doing with your designs
and as an entrepreneur my hat's off to
you just want to say you're inspiring
not only myself but so many people so i
want to say thank you for that
what are you an entrepreneur wow thank
you i'm a bit of an entrepreneur myself
i have five different companies but i'm
not about to get into myself
this isn't about me right now i do want
to share a gift of one of my designs
this is actually my most famous design
this is something that
i actually designed myself and
there's only 30 of these so
i want to give oh my god wow brand new
high fashion that is amazing
that's for you that
that's super nice i've always wanted one
of those yeah
thank you and next up i want to say
dan thank you so much for putting this
whole thing together i know it was not
easy especially with these two
knuckleheads they canceled like six
times so
i want to say thank you for making it
happen i have a gift for you
bring it over here for me wow um this is
a shirt of my album cover here
oh that's nice the reason that makes
this special is we actually got these
shirts in last night there was only two
and one of them for me and one of them
is for you dan wow that is exclusive
yeah that's ugly is beautiful it came
out yesterday
go stream it everywhere wow thank you
oliver
very kind that was super nice thank you
and ian i just want to say i admire your
work
i love what you're doing with powerpoint
and i know that you did collect
bill delphine's spit i saw that you had
her jar of spit and so i wanted to give
you a little gift this is
something from my personal collection
i've actually oh
uh this is actually my spit that's a
little soft throw that out
please no no no that is so disgusting
bro
that's for you ian i just want you to
know that you can put that next to your
collection
that's disgusting bro please don't
that actually that makes me so nauseous
seeing that and like belle's delphine i
mean
she's like a sex icon so
it was somewhat acceptable but are you
saying oliver isn't
yeah no i'm not i am definitely saying
he's not i mean
okay you can base that base on my i just
gagged a little bit look did you not
what did we talk about dude stop okay go
ahead go ahead the gifts are really nice
you're a [ __ ]
50 year old man dude sorry sorry sorry
sorry go ahead go ahead
i'm so sick of people who talk [ __ ]
because they're not happy with the way
they look and you're a great example of
that ethan
you're a guy who can't find love in his
life he can't seem to find love in his
own self he looks in the mirror and he
says
who is this i'm not happy with this this
guy i see and you know what you let it
out on guys like me
you try to take it out and guess what
that's [ __ ] pathetic
you're right i'm sorry i just want to
move forward
this next gift is going to be for
someone who i'm also a big fan of
zach the intern i'm a big fan of what
you've done for the podcast
you've taken things from here to here i
want to give you this gift to let you
know
i acknowledge your contributions and
i got you a little hair moisturizer oh
is it i think i know what it is
first off there's a little letter
with love from oliver tree it's private
just for him
why did you why did you heard it hey
mayonnaise for zach you'll surely have
my shoes
in his hair so do what you want with
that egg salad or hair you know
it's for you i'm sure he'll appreciate
that
do you watch 90 day fiance yeah big fan
nice big head in the house i'm just
kidding i never wasted my time watching
that [ __ ] i'm making art i'm very
busy
yeah um let's see here
i'm trying to think is that it is that
all the gifts we have
i think that's everything um
was there anything for ethan
is there anything else here no
that's everything you didn't get me
anything
grab me a sticker
oliver hey can someone grab me a sticker
or something
oliver grab me a pen too grab me a pen
so ethan i know you're a huge fan i'm
going to give you a signed sticker
this is something that's definitely
going to be worth a lot one day so i
just want you to know
this is probably worth more than
anything anyone's getting today so don't
feel left out
what wait all those gifts
i mean i'll just honestly do you know
what i'm gonna do
i'm going to throw that out and i'm
going to take for you i'm going to take
theodore's spark scooter
i don't think that's a good idea i'm
going to take theodore spark scooter
because frankly he's too young
frankly i think it's a little
irresponsible for you to be giving that
to our
one-year-old son what the [ __ ] oh wait
there's one more gift let me get this
oh this is actually a painting i painted
it myself and i wanted to give this to
you gila
wait why does he look at another gift
can you give it to me
thank you i love it that's for me to you
and i just want you to know
you could put that anywhere made by me
can you stop hitting on my wife bro
your guy's audio cut off i can't hear
[ __ ] i said stop hitting on my wife bro
one second we're having some technical
somebody [ __ ] help me out here
was he being serious yeah no he's not
being
is this a stick what is that why is
there a guy that looks like you just
bro do all your helpers dress like you
can we just have a conversation that's
really all i want
i feel like you came on here you try to
make it your show you forget that other
people actually have a show and maybe
they want to conduct it how they do
their own show so maybe we could try
that
i'll just be straight up dude no one
wants to hear your [ __ ] spiel
i don't have a spiel i just want to ask
you some questions because this is a
podcast
people need to be able to listen they
want to listen not just like yelling and
like
you're handing out gifts i mean this is
a podcast you know it's an audio thing
like it doesn't even make sense what are
people listening to dead air
for five minutes let's just talk you
know what dude
you're the one who invited me on the
show and you had nothing planned so i
figured i would take it upon myself
to plan some [ __ ] out because a guy like
you has no idea what he's doing
okay damn you really got bruised up i
know
whoa okay oliver
so shouldn't you cover it with something
i did i put a bunch of echinacea on
there and i did a little
neosporin um i have a question
is pink your favorite color no
my favorite color is actually gold i
don't know if you can see my scooter
i do see that let's talk about life okay
you've got a lot going on you've been
building up to this album for a long
time
and all of a sudden covid hits that's
gotta feel like a real [ __ ]
that's gotta feel like i mean on a real
personal level you gotta feel like this
really [ __ ] sucks
you can't tour the album the release
date is
is all wacky i mean it's gotta really
[ __ ] suck
oh it sucks more than you can imagine
ultimately this is the worst time to
ever release the album and there's many
reasons to that
but the fact is is this is the worst
time to drop an album
in the course of history and the fact is
i wouldn't want to drop an album if it
was up to me i would never have dropped
the album
i love pushing [ __ ] back i would keep
pushing it back but the truth is during
this dark time
when people are going through it they
need messages of positivity they need
antidotes to help them get through these
dark times and ultimately
this music is filled with that it's
riddled with so many positive messages
and things to help people get through
darkest moments
so ultimately even though it's the worst
time to release music in the
course of human history i can strongly
say that this music is also needed more
than ever at this time
right that is true and the truth is
people are so unhappy with themselves
they hate themselves
i can see it in ethan you know the way
he takes out his aggression on me
just in general when you see people that
take out aggression on other people
they're just unhappy with their selves
they're unhappy with their own lives and
ethan
i don't know how unhappy you are but the
truth is most people are unhappy and we
all
get to be unhappy at some point but the
fact is
is that when we internalize this hatred
we push it out on others
we push the [ __ ] outwards and so you
know if we can learn to be able to
love ourselves on a micro level and not
have that hatred within we're way less
likely to
put that venom outwards and the truth is
that's a big part of how things have
gotten
so [ __ ] up in this world is that we
literally have so much hate
within ourselves we externalize it on
those around us
and are you i have you got to be worried
about like
how are you making money because you got
all these people on payroll you got this
album coming out that probably not that
many people are going to buy
at least not enough to like justify
everything that's going on
and you can't tour so how are your are
you dudes working for free i mean you
probably have debt with the record label
are you worried about money oh i have
tremendous debt with the record label
but that's just like a bank and
they basically just keep giving you
funds when you need them for the art but
they don't actually really pay for your
living they don't really pay for [ __ ]
except for the art itself
and the truth is i'm not making money
right now
i'm living off of money from six or
seven years ago
and i'm lucky that i have a little bit
to be able to spend some time focusing
on my new endeavors
spent a lot of time working on a couple
different screenplays so i'm currently
in the process of making my segue out of
music and trying to get into the world
of film
is that for real or is that a goof are
you really writing scripts
you want to have a serious conversation
no i'm serious i'm interested what kind
of films are you making
i'm not making features yet i'm writing
them so i know what kind of films are
i'm not trying to split hairs i just
want to know about your interest in film
one of them is a coming to age a love
story
and the other one is ultimately a
thriller
about you know the [ __ ] up side of
this world
and are you do you star in them are you
just a writer no
no i'm writing and directing them uh i'm
also working on production i'm building
a production company right now so i've
been focused on being a producer as well
but i've been focusing more on smaller
scale stuff as far as big scale
productions go
we've been doing a lot of short film
stuff a lot of music videos and things
that are more two to three day shoots
sometimes
up to a couple months with some of my
bigger music videos but um
ultimately i did film a feature length
documentary this year and we haven't
started editing it yet because we're
editing a lot of other documentaries
we've made
but we have a youtube series coming out
which will be one documentary a month
they're anywhere from 15 minutes to
you know 45 to an hour they'll get
longer as the series progresses but
basically we've been working on that for
two years now and that's kind of the
more long-form content i've been
directing is
that's more of the long-form films i've
been working on is just documentary
stuff but it allows me to really
make the most out of my low budget
scenarios
can you tease some of the topics you've
been uh
documenting um
basically my travels around the world
everything from
competing against the number one scooter
rider in australia named
ryan williams i competed against him for
the world title
um anything from that to shooting behind
the scenes of
these big scale multi-million dollar
music videos
to you know the creation of the world's
biggest scooter
we've done all kinds of topics around
just exploring the globe
kind of you get a chance to come travel
the world with me and my bandmates
oh okay so it is more of oliver tree
yeah that is but i'm not talking about
those as features or anything those are
for youtube and they are
film based they're not youtube videos
however i'm venturing forwards to the
world of feature films and doing
full-on getting behind the camera
removing myself
from in front of it and being able to be
a storyteller
and really get behind the power and
yield the full power behind the camera
because i'm done being a [ __ ] puppet
man
oliver how do your parents feel about
like everything you're doing
my parents they love me man i'm
definitely the favorite son i mean if
you were to ask me if they liked me or
my brother more it would definitely be
me
i could help maybe i feel that way i
know that feeling yeah
i feel like your parents would say that
about you too ila or your mom
you can't say that though yeah well my
parents
have said that so yeah my parents have
said that too
kind of you know you could just okay
stop lying to yourself
what's going on here oh my god
i'm allergic to [ __ ] okay
so uh oliver would you like to watch one
of your music videos
of course man i'd love to watch a music
video what are you thinking i want to
say on a real note here
um that your videos are always the best
videos
um out there yeah they're every single
time you
ma managed to make it
just not repetitive it's always
interesting and
unexpected and really well made and
creative
and it's the best all right calm slow
down yo
jesus like what's going on with you two
it's crazy well ethan i think it's good
recognize what a real youtube video
should look like and it's really not
about a youtube video
it's about making a film and it's about
the next generation of youtubers
it's fine it's a good video dude you
don't have to go on and on about it
let's just watch it bro
do you want to watch it or not i'm
trying to promote your [ __ ] whatever
so-called music
all right here we go oliver are you
ready i'm ready
so do you want me to critique it or just
watch it
um i don't know what's your preference i
mean do you want to critique it at the
end or do you want to pause it like you
always do and ruin the video
i don't know what do you what should i
do should i just let it play through i
think i should decide because that's
really
hurtful i mean yeah you decide because i
feel like it i feel like if people want
to what go
watch the video interrupted they could
just do it on youtube right that's an i
feel like that's a great that's a good
point
maybe just give it like a good amount
you want me to play it through i'll just
play it through
the whole thing man it's your show
your big ego trip bro your name's on the
thing hey oliver are you gonna claim my
[ __ ] i know you guys need the money
don't claim my [ __ ] please we might
don't claim it because by the way i'm
gonna talk more about it
still i know oh okay right i'm looking
at oliver right yeah
okay oliver i'm gonna play your [ __ ]
uh video so just let it so don't
interrupt
i'm just gonna let you have your mom you
can pause it whenever you can say
whatever but you know i know that you
don't know much about cinema so i'm
going to take it with a grain of salt
but hilo i would love to hear anything
you have to say okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
smiles
that's how you cover up your cavities
[Music]
[Applause]
when is it enough how bad do you need
that stuff
what's it all for why does it seem like
you're snowing
what's it all for was it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how you cover up your cavities
[Music]
that should look
[Music]
i love that [ __ ] dude does it seem like
turns out
[Music]
oh ela's requested a pause so ila
requested a pause
well i'm you want to discuss i need to
make a whole scene about the pause
well i don't know you guys made this
whole big deal about me not possible
said hilo was welcome to choose pausing
you and i feel like
first of all fantastic video and i do
love the song too the song's
absolute banger i'm stoked yes beautiful
it's out now streaming everywhere
now what like where did you guys shoot
this that was lake pyro
and do you think it's appropriate that
you guys ran those old people off their
water scooters i think that's what
they're called
to tell you the truth um that may have
been where i did cross over a line
but you know i think at the end of the
day
there were great sports about it and
they didn't mind too much we told them
we were filming a video and
you know and we showed them the link and
we actually gave them a credit
in the youtube description which i think
should still be in there i'm not sure if
the label took it down or not but we did
shout them out
oh so they didn't even they weren't even
actors you just ran them off
yeah they were actually at the lake and
we saw a couple different people that
were there and we approached them and
out of all the different people we saw
that day it's actually
it was them and there was one other
gentleman as well who
ended up being in the film but we just
were pulling off people from the lake
um you actually tell us how some of
those shots were
done say that again which one
um the shots i'm i'm just actually so
curious about all these shots how they
were really done
um the stuff with you on the scooter the
water scooter
looks real well i think so
that was crazy that alone i mean i'll
just prefix by saying this about this
video this was
my greatest failure as far as an artist
goes
i think it's one of my favorite videos
that i've made but the way that it
performed was just such a tremendous
failure
and i i was not only as far as
performance goes
on views and whatnot but really just how
much the actual investment costed this
is my most expensive video to date
really cost yeah it was a little bit
over two million dollars by the end of
the process
and so it took us two or three months
just to finish well
there's two and a half months of filming
but then it's like two to three months
of
vfx and then you have you know you're
doing coloring and then you go back and
you have to redo vfx and just this game
that we just kept playing
we always edit these videos up till the
very last night but this was something
that
ultimately for that amount of money i
feel like i definitely got a little
ripped off
um my producer who i'm not exactly sure
where he is right now i haven't seen him
since i shot this video but
he literally he helped me achieve the
dream
but it was at least double the price he
said it was going to be so that was
something that was a huge financial
burden but the scooter stuff
specifically so as many people know i
have been a professional scooter i grew
up in the pro circuit
when i was 18 i had a crash during a
semi-final run that actually put me out
and um i kind of changed over to music
after that point but i have a background
with action sports
bmxing scootering everything from
rollerblading
even skateboarding a few people know
that but i used to long board and i used
to do downhill longboarding
um but i have a background with all this
stuff so i
know how to rotate a scooter i know how
to rotate a bmx bike
so to be able to learn how to actually
do a backflip off the wake
that took a couple months of me actually
learning i'm pretty used to jet skiing
or something
family vacations and when not growing up
but it wasn't something i ever learned
how to do tricks and these are actually
different types of ski do's
and the way you actually work is you
have to push your body tremendously off
the wake and you use it as a lip of a
ramp
and so to learn how to use the wave as a
ramp is a little different than dirt
or wood which is what i'm used to
flipping on normally but after the
learning curve of a couple months i was
able to get past
you know learning how to do the natural
learning how to do a natural jump and
actually be able to fly this thing and
i think the results spoke for themselves
the other thing that was really
complicated was the actual jet pack
stuff
that was pretty [ __ ] crazy because we
have to understand is those jet packs
they're not that hard to learn how to
ride it's about
20 minutes and even someone like you
ethan would probably be able to figure
out how to do it
but the thing is to learn how to
actually do the tricks and the body
maneuvers
and the burials that i was doing it
takes a couple months so that was also
something i spent every day i spent some
time in san diego
and i was training from one of the best
guys in the world there wow
i don't i wonder why guys please go
watch this music video it's got 11
million views and i feel like
i don't know why isn't it strange how
sometimes videos
they they get there they don't but i
think the songs are banger i think the
video is a banger i just don't get it
why you know what i mean i don't get it
either man i appreciate you saying that
because
the truth is to spend that amount of
time and energy like i spent six months
total trying to make this piece
and for me to put that amount of money
and that much time towards it
it's you know it's the kind of thing
where you you hope that that would never
happen and this isn't in your worst case
scenarios that it would go that bad but
because sometimes that's life and those
failures are you know if you keep going
and you keep needing to make stuff
after a failure like that it's like well
that's just what you're here to do
because you can't stop
because i stopped i remember hurt i
remember last time you're on you made
hurt and that music video was great was
really
really good it got age restricted but
i'm happy to see it almost has 40
million views so it did pretty good in
the end right
yeah i mean i would say that 40 million
is definitely not good especially for a
major label artist who's
invested multi millions of dollars into
his films and ideas and the truth is
it's nowhere near what it should be
regardless age restricted or not
that number is not impressive to me now
so what to you
is like what you would be a good
performing video
i don't know like a billion a billion
yeah i mean there are some that are up
there
for sure a billion and there's a lot of
billion videos and i'm
working this year to ensure that one of
these videos do get a billion so
that's my main focus right now so this
one that we just washed is about
like what one one thousandth away
yeah so let's keep watching i mean i
agree with everything you said though it
is really fantastic and i do love
what is that car when the doors that's a
delorean yeah it's delorean
custom designed from this guy up in san
francisco his name was david laurian
and he built this thing and we actually
painted it pink custom for the shoot and
he was so [ __ ] pissed off man
was the uh i i have a question oliver
was the uh the opening is that an homage
to uh the window liquor video
excuse me i think that's a no there's
another music video that that
that is pretty much exactly the opening
of your video is that an homage who is
it by who's it by
by by effects twins is a very famous
music video
wait did you plagiarize some idea
no definitely not i do all my [ __ ]
original so okay um
are you talking about must be seen with
the limousine yeah with the limousine
yeah
oh that scene yeah i took that from apex
twin
[Laughter]
so is that pink car for sale
uh we actually sold it in i believe
november
but that thing was [ __ ] incredible
and i used to take that thing out to
like pyro on weekends
and i had to spend a little bit of time
learning how to write it but it was
nothing like what the learning curve was
for something like flipping a jet ski or
learning how to
fully walk on water with a water jet
pack but truth be told that thing
presented its own problems
and i found that you know riding on
water
didn't really get the effect i was
looking for it made it hard for you to
see my face while i was singing and the
water splashing
so you know in a lot of ways this video
was a major failure and i think
if you look at other water films
especially the movie water world i mean
that was a tremendous failure in a lot
of ways this was my water world
right have you seen water world eeler
they say it's one of the worst films
ever no i don't yeah maybe we should
watch that
so i'm gonna i'm gonna continue oliver
and um
this is cash machine by oliver is it
tree or
nickel can we say we would just let
people watch like the full video
well yeah oh we don't want to finish it
thank you gila thank you gila you're
such a sweet angel
i thought we wanted to watch it i mean
they can do both the opposite so
they go and watch guys this is a tease
go finish the video over at
oliver trees youtube channel and
subscribe as well
you're not going to show the best
[ __ ] part you guys make up your mind
do you want me to watch it or no
no it's whatever if they want to watch
the best part they can go watch it
themselves
stop it stop it no no no no not stop
[Music]
[Music]
i think we got something big here bobby
hold on man
hold on
what the hell is that
[Music]
can i ask what's the meaning behind the
uh can i ask what's the meaning behind
the the man in the yellow
bro are you [ __ ] serious you're gonna
pause the video for some stupid question
like that
[Music]
there you go done wow
so who's the man in yellow
oh that guy yeah
i will never say so this one
was great but uh underperformed we don't
know why
why i don't know why the song is great
the video is great what's happening on
youtube eela
i mean i think it's got a lot of views
though i think
we should i would disagree well for 2
million consider it a failure
well hold on it's got it's been seven
months and it has 11 million views
i mean that's a lot but i agree with
oliver i think maybe for youtubers like
you guys but i'm talking about a whole
different bracket no i agree i agree
should have more views
i think it should be if i had the i
think it should be at you know
20 30 million right now i would say at
least double that 60 70 maybe 100
right yeah i could see that too if the
music was better maybe
all right let's watch another one this
one's actually done quite well for
itself
three months ago and it's at 60 million
are you happy with the performance of
let me down no i'm not
all right fair enough you know
it's important to it's important to keep
pushing right for higher
harder
so before we watch it do you want to say
anything about it
this is let me down by oliver i will say
this
this was a major mix-up on behalf of the
label i was told i was going to be doing
a live performance video for this
channel on youtube called colors
and so i go and i show up to the shoot
and what i think is a color shoot
and i get there and i notice certain
people i recognize certain faces there's
certain people on my team working
there's people that i worked with as
producers
that are on the set and i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on here this doesn't
look like a color
set and i found out that the [ __ ]
label set this [ __ ] up
and tricked my ass so that i thought i
was doing a color session which are
these videos that end up getting you
know
hundreds of millions of plays and
meanwhile i'm doing some [ __ ] that is a
fake video that
the label has set up for my youtube
channel i was so [ __ ] pissed off when
i found out it wasn't a real one i
didn't want to release it
but contractually i am obligated to put
out a certain amount of music videos
every month so at that point
i was really hurting and i needed at
least one to go so i just put it out how
to drop it
but ironically it is outperforming the
one you spent two million dollars in a
year
making yeah that's because the thing is
that i'm not making
music videos to make the best marketing
for a music video
i'm trying to make a [ __ ] scene from
a feature-length action film you know
the truth is i'm using this as
a chance to be able to direct
feature-length films that are just
really small
short little snippets of them because
the thing is who's going to give me
money to do that
i don't really care to make the most
effective music video i'm trying to make
the craziest scene i can think up in my
head
and try to actualize that and realize
that it's really not about marketing the
music
i'm just tricking the label into
investing and giving me a bunch of money
so i can start my filmmaking career
should you be saying that publicly at
this point i don't give a [ __ ] because
i'm done with music
i'm done with the oliver tree project
this is my last album it's going to be
my best album
doesn't really matter man i'm out and
it's like at that point
yeah let him hear the truth [ __ ] it well
let's watch the video let's see
well do you want to watch this one
because it sounds like you don't even
like this one because you got tricked
into it
let's watch it let's watch it i think
it's good and i really like this song
play a little you can just play a
snippet but okay
honestly i'm pissed about the whole
experience so let me down by oliver tree
this is really exciting dude
this is super exciting your music video
i like how you ate a sandwich
[Music]
i do love this song
[Music]
[Music]
sorry go ahead you don't want to watch
it video
this video cost five grand man i spent
two million on the last one you think i
want to watch this no
maybe it should sign maybe you don't
need to spend two million dollars on a
music video but i i hear you you you
wanna you wanna
what do you know about making videos no
you're right i mean
you ever made a little scene with more
than two youtube filmers
no i haven't not like not like that last
video for sure i haven't made anything
like that
well then let's keep the [ __ ]
comments down to a minimum guy
okay fair enough so that video don't let
me down
now what is that just let me down dude
don't let me down
cause you say let don't let me down in
the song so why would you
name it let me down i don't know man
it's a pop song let's make it simpler
because then you got guys trying to add
in all these extra syllables it's like
dude just
let me down that's it yeah but the
character he says don't let me down
but you know what i'm saying like yeah
it says please don't let me down you
think i'm going to just put every word
that's in the song
yeah it'll do you could say please don't
let me down i mean i've seen song titles
that long before in my life but
regardless
what is what are we talking about are
you i've heard you said that this is
about
um your fans being upset that you kept
delaying your album is that true
yeah so after i canceled the album and i
lost 150
000 in the first couple days there i did
feel like i let a lot of people down and
i ultimately felt
and i ultimately felt like i let myself
down and and especially the fans so
i made this song as an apology for
myself to the fans
and let them know you know i did let you
down and i do feel like i did that but
you know i'm here to make amends
and i will make the greatest album i
could possibly make
and that's all i can do so shouldn't you
shouldn't it be called i won't let you
down maybe that would be a better title
if you were to title if maybe you were
songs before
cop i've actually written a couple and i
if you're asking me at the songwriter
you may want to change it just more
literally to i won't
i oliver tree will not let you down
again maybe for the title
what if you made a song that said i
ethan klein will finally give up my
youtube career because i'm a
[ __ ] scam artist i'm not a scam
artist why would you even say that i
mean i am not i'm not even saying
anything personal i'm giving you
constructive
feedback that clearly you can't handle
you're a [ __ ] scam artist
right okay uh
so that's called don't let me so that
song is called
i oliver tree promise not to let you
down again on his youtube channel
so oliver is this the reason you're mad
every time
we run into each other i feel like
you're always angry at me and i think it
has something to do with the fact that
my action figure's so much better than
yours
look at your action figure dude he looks
so [ __ ] ridiculous look at mine you
see something that's something
potentially arguably one of the greatest
characters ever made and when i look at
yours i see something that's very try
hard
something very wannabe trying to be hip
and really
i look at mine and i just see something
that's iconic and classic
when i look at yours i see a guy who
thinks he's trendy and thinks he's with
hip with the times but really
it's some 50 year old [ __ ] youtuber
dude mike comes with a vape cloud yours
doesn't even have feet bro
like where's your feet you have no feet
do you not see the [ __ ] pants dude
that's iconic and that's something you
don't understand
you're too busy
i'm carving my own life mine comes with
a smoke cloud of smoke you can't compete
without a smoke dude all that is is a
bunch of toilet paper dude let me ask
you something
can i may i ask you something daniel
brown
he's the guy that made these two action
figures i want to give him some love
but then if you go look at the daniel
brown if you want to look at the
comments he says
a couple of legends right but then
technically one someone said at least
one of them
is one of them at least so i'm assuming
he's talking about you
yeah of course i mean you're the one
you're the one that's not a legend to
clarify
i'm the legend excuse me
you didn't make any sense yeah i don't
understand what the [ __ ] exactly let me
rephrase
buddy this guy this guy says one of them
at least is a legend
and i know he i'm the legend so he's
kind of dissing you when he says that
he said who's the legend me no he said
one of them at least is a legend but
he was leaving it open for
interpretation
right and he was referring to me this
thing keeps [ __ ] turning off
is can we get the battery check on this
so ela you've magically got on
uh the gift that oliver gave you yes
i'm actually oliver you look just like
oliver
except way better looking right oliver
she
changed my mind i think we can both
agree on that
yeah we don't disagree on that i was
gonna say i'm just gonna change my name
to oliver you're oliver klein yeah so
i'm i'm [ __ ] oliver now
your biggest dream ethan finally all now
all we're coming
to real so can you hand me my gift it
kind of reminds me of
it's kind of almost like a cartman from
south park cosplay
where you're cartman she kind of looks
like cartman man
with the hat this is mine this is what
it it's just
it's a sticker and it just says h3h3 on
the back this
this is [ __ ] bro
this is just a promotion it's just your
instagram on the back
which i'm not even going to say because
i don't want to promote it
hey shout it out shout it out no i'm not
going to do it
also this thing is just oliver trey fan
art
oh bro you didn't even make this what
the hell no that's disrespectful to your
fan who made it first of all like how
are you gonna re-gift someone's fan art
to you
but um thank you vivianne i love it
vivian this is how much your favorite
artist cares about you
he just gave us your art i'm gonna put
it up on the wall
it says i love you so can i read this i
mean it's my gift
no it's my gift it's my personal do not
read that hello
i love you so much i can't believe i'm
gonna see you
i hope your leg gets better and that you
keep doing amazing
if you wanna talk to me i'm not gonna
post this uh private information but she
drew herself here and she looks cute so
you may want her number
that's her oh [ __ ] it has her info on it
we'll learn that
[ __ ] idiot i don't think you could
rid it
so this is a lie because this says
everything
everything's alive made by oliver tree
there's literally nothing genuine and
then here we've got spit
which actually does look real i'm sad to
see so that's my real spitfire this is
this is the only genuine gift we got
either once you put this on the desk
without telling me that's disgusting
bro [ __ ] you for spitting in a jar
giving that to me that's so disgusting
you sick [ __ ]
you [ __ ] monster bro
there's like chunks there's hell of
chunks in there
yo this is a can we just you know you
understand that this is a biohazard
we're living in covid era you brought in
a vial of
this is disgusting this is a biohazard
get this the [ __ ] out of here
i'm serious this is gonna be worth a lot
of money one day
i'm gonna clone you bro do it see what i
care man i've already got so many
[ __ ] clones
can we see your clone again can you come
in the screen
where's the intern i thought it was a
clone
flyer it could be cold this is
yes i'm impressed oh it's hollow you
[ __ ] phony
[ __ ] you ethan you're a piece of [ __ ]
you're not worth anything more than that
it's kind of for my son you [ __ ] it's
kind of
genius compared to how we do yeah it is
actually yeah it is genius
this is actually the plan that could
make a beanie that sat
30 [ __ ] we actually were even worried
about that
but we showed the making of this is just
some this is some
hollywood [ __ ] [ __ ] you
that's real art ethan and what you do
makes a mockery break my art
this is oliver this is oliver when he uh
this is oliver when he gets in bed with
a girl
all right can't get it up
i gotta wash my hands dude his violent
spit is on the floor i'm telling you why
did you bring that into the house
put that away somewhere instant
karma [ __ ] so
hang on let me just get rid of all this
wait i'm destroying it just get this out
of my
face did you see those chunks in there
yes
oh i see you're i see your trick
what are you doing stop showing that
[ __ ] take that off don't put that in the
[ __ ] video
i give you guys gifts and this is how
you [ __ ] thank me this is an
embarrassment
there's more can we just move on there's
more gifts dude i brought a lot of [ __ ]
oh do we definitely go twitters are here
dude that says eight plus you understand
our son is one right
you can never start him too early then
that's what i'm pretty sure you can
trying to hurt our son i don't get it no
dude i'm trying to
watch out for you and all you do is
[ __ ] show me you're his godfather and
you're putting him home
all right let's move on you live
you live with like five dudes right you
live with your whole posse
no why do you say what how many people
do you live with
two okay
my son we're getting into personal stuff
right now dude what are you trying to do
well what i'm getting
about what i'm getting at if you'll
allow me is you just sent me a vial of
spit
explain to me how that's not a biohazard
and how you probably send that [ __ ] to
you dude i don't even want to give you
any [ __ ] presents
that's for ian to put next to this
[ __ ] rest of his collection dude
he has other spit jars i figured you'd
be interested in compliment
have you been tested for coconuts i've
been tested
yeah when were you tested last two
months ago
two months ago i was tested and i didn't
have any of the antibodies
dude this is dude you i think you may
have committed a federal crime sending
us that spin
oh man i'm just waiting for the days to
count down
you want me to die was that
assassination
i don't know man i'm not going to get
into it here we have there's a huge deal
we've got a huge deal
everybody listen up little
ricky little richard a little ricky
little ricky zr3 dude ricky portrayed
v4 okay zr did you not listen to the
album did you not hear the [ __ ] song
1993 the second song i would have hoped
you made it to the second song
no i bailed about ten percent in to the
first song
little little ricky little little ricky
little richard go ahead sorry there's
like a delay
the only delay is in your [ __ ]
cognitive ability
go ahead
can i talk yes
little richard now go ahead i won't talk
anymore i'll let you talk about little
richard
little ricky is the [ __ ] future of
music this guy is so [ __ ] progressive
the ways
he's producing out his tracks he's built
his own daw
which is a digital audio workstation
little ricky designed his own daw
just to give you an idea i don't know if
that even can compute to someone like
you ethan but
literally he's helping design gear that
designs
sounds he's working on sound designing
software
and the thing is that i got a chance to
work are you listening
[Music]
no i'm totally listening keep going i
was just discussing my dinner plans with
ila
okay dude this interview is done hey
little ricky is so [ __ ] epic that you
should be so lucky to have me talk about
him on your [ __ ] ass show
[Laughter]
do we have a sample of little ricky can
we pull it up
wait we back to scooter gags come on we
said we would leave the scooter
can i ask you some questions yeah yeah
yeah yeah
have you given any thoughts to
unconventional
touring now that you cannot do great
conventional touring go ahead i
dare you to answer that's an incredible
question and that's a question that
actually
there are answers for and some of these
questions that ethan is presenting me
it's like
what do you want me to say dude you're
just trying to get some click bait drama
no what your [ __ ] deal dude so answer
the question
what's the question
can i have the question again go ahead
hila have you given any thoughts to
unconventional kinds of
touring now that
touring is basically out of the question
yes i'm looking at doing a full live
concert
live streamed onto the youtube
is it pay-per-view or free um
you'd like to know that wouldn't you
what would you what kind of job would
you consider picking up if you ever
come in need of money um you're saying
his music career doesn't pan out and he
needs to get a day job
go ahead oliver i'm working towards film
i'm working on no a job that actually
pays money go ahead
like actually making money i mean like
actually you need to make an income goal
what do you mean like selling diapers on
youtube
videos yeah uh well what was the ad for
what was the ad for in this episode
again
the ad not diapers i don't want you to
know my sponsors
yeah well dude it seems like it's quite
apparent that you get the lowest common
denominator of sponsors
and you're coming after me about how i
make money if the music
doesn't work out tell me what day job
you will pursue to make an
income because you'll need to make
income yeah i want to be president
oliver but like stepping stones dude if
it came down to it i'd just go back to
scootering
i had a whole [ __ ] scene no i said
jobs that pay money bro
delivery it matters uber i'm friends
with some of the biggest scooter riders
in the world
and these dudes have multiple houses so
what do you know about that
what's on the head of your scooter why
are there moose horns on your scooter
so this was actually antlers from an elk
that my grandfather killed
and this is from 1906. and if you look
closely this one's actually kind of
[ __ ] up
i need to get a better setup because the
taxidermist that actually had set these
up for me
he didn't do a very good job clamping it
in and so now it's kind of
[ __ ] up but do you think i gotta clean
up for the next interview is it
disrespectful to
to spray painted gold
no no these actually were gold initially
it's a very special type of elk
very few people know about it but
i'm sorry what was the question
ah this is so [ __ ] all right so
so why should people go listen to your
album give me one reason why should
people go listen your album
this music is something that has never
been released before
it's unique in the sense of the way it
fuses
genres together so the way it mixes
contemporary rock alternative with
electronic production
with hip hop with pop sensibility
it's fusion it's inspired by the genre
that the gorillas was creating as far as
fusion goes
and it's the next generation that comes
post gorillas that first album that they
put out
was literally 20 years ago and now this
is kind of the next generation the kids
growing up listening to that music and
what they make
so what makes this album really special
is the way it blends genres together
there's some very unique genre fusion
that you will not find anywhere else and
i can guarantee you that
what do you say to people who say that
your music is just a dollar store 21
pilot
i would say everybody knows 21 pilots
ripped my [ __ ] off i was doing this [ __ ]
for [ __ ] 10 plus years
no one caught on to it and 21 pilots
used to follow me on soundcloud and
that's just a [ __ ] fact
hmm yeah and all of a sudden somehow
he's got a similar sound to me 10 years
later
oh it's shocking and people ask how it
happened well tyler joseph used to
follow me on soundcloud mm-hmm
interesting is there any legal action in
the works
at this point i've actually have to
decline on that answer the legal counsel
has advised me not to say anything but
i will say this yes there will be
repercussions indefinitely
are you circumcised or uncircumcised
okay dude let's wrap this one up
you got any real questions are you gonna
just keep making a mockery of my life's
work
have you ever thought about going on
tour like have you heard about some
artists are doing drive-through
they're putting on shows at like
drive-ins where people can come watching
their car
have you heard about that it's pretty
cool no i haven't that's a pretty good
idea though you haven't heard about that
no we had a friend of the show on marc
rubier
he's like he's a performing artist and
he was doing shows
at he did a tour all around the country
at uh drive-in theaters and people could
come watch him live
in their cars was that sounds like a
hell of a guy man
is that something you would consider
doing um
ultimately no i'm pretty busy i'm doing
a lot of [ __ ] and like i said i'm trying
to move away from music
and so for me to try to take on some new
projects like that i feel like it
wouldn't serve me for my film career and
some of these new endeavors i'm trying
to work on
fascinating
oliver thoughts on pineapple on pizza
love it or hate it
i knew that'd get you back in here
not a bad question so truth be told it
gets a bad rap a lot of people say
pineapples do not belong on pizza i know
in italy it's basically a crime
but i have to disagree i think
pineapples do believe on pizza
i think pineapples do belong on pizza
and i'll say this right now
tastes like a goddamn christmas miracle
i agree with you oliver i feel like we
just found common ground
what else do you like so if you're
putting pineapple on your pie which i
think is a good idea to start with
now what accompaniments do you add to
the pineapple because that makes a big
difference
this is where people diverge for like
for example my
my favorite is like you add some black
olives and then
if you really want to get weird some
jalapenos go you next
okay i start with black olives next
thing i'm going to put some jalapenos on
there
bro wow
jalapeno poppers the whole popper
the whole thing
and on top of that i put some
lightly crusted canadian bacon maybe
with some
a little lemon zest potentially some
anchovies
zest and artichoke hearts i love them i
love artichoke
yeah i like artichoke hearts now oliver
is there any anything substantial you
want to talk about are we just going to
[ __ ]
um tell you the truth i thought you guys
would be the ones asking the questions
usually what happens is and i've done a
lot of these interviews is the person
actually
spends some time that like puts together
a list of things they want to ask that
would potentially be valuable to the
audience and what we see in this
situation
is you know uh two hosts that are
you know i'm not gonna say anything
other than two people who have not
done any homework or research or you
know they've shown
you know consistent disrespect i would
say hilo you have been pleasant to talk
to
ethan you on the other hand it's been
hard trying to navigate an interview
with the guy who hasn't come up with a
single question
is there anything in your head that made
you think maybe this would be a good
chance to actually
do something for once and actually try
to put some energy into your podcast
if we can even call it that is this a
podcast for one is this or
are we can i ask you do you have any
better name for us for this
show well because i mean ultimately yeah
yeah do you have any questions h3 yeah
seems about right it's a pretty bad name
oliver do you have any questions for me
yeah i do actually
i was wondering how long have you been
running this fake charity
well it's a real charity and we started
it
about 90 days ago has it been that long
wow
that's crazy so it just came up out of
thin air right when money was starting
to get low
yes that's why we did it um
that's crazy what a coincidence
so let me ask you a question one thing i
will say is
i do want to apologize about the
painting that i gave you guys last time
i don't know if you remember
yeah that's right i'm not sure if you
remember but um we love this i actually
gave a painting
oh you guys actually didn't throw it
away no no i love this
it's right here so oh it's just hiding
underneath the table that's awesome
i was thinking maybe some wall space
maybe something where you know
it's complaining when they come in so
what about it
i just wanted to apologize about it and
i wanted to say i understand why i
didn't put it on your wall
because the end product was garbage it
was supposed to be an oil painting it
was supposed to be something that was
a much higher level of art and what my
sister ended up coming up with
was a rush job last minute piece of [ __ ]
colored pencil job
and so i wanted to apologize and there
is a video that's from over a year ago
when i was trying to get this painting
made for you guys and i just wanted to
share with you guys
that i am sorry and i know it didn't
have the full 30 stack that i had
promised you before i know it didn't
have the 30 sec that i promised before
and that's why i wanted to give you that
gift today
but there's a video and if you want to
check it out you're more than welcome to
let that play
ethan and gila just had a child hold on
i'm watching a video now
so i wanted to present them with
something special how much this is a
super talent container she does oil
paintings
i had her make this piece i commissioned
her i mean i came up with the whole idea
and everything
and not to give her too much credit i'm
very excited to present this to the
family
but i do the podcast tomorrow i think
they will be pleasantly surprised
you [ __ ] kidding me this is like it's
dark colored pencil
she said it took four weeks because it
was oil paint what the [ __ ]
is this this is not gonna work i asked
for a 4x4 this is not even two by two
dude this interview is gonna be
[ __ ] ruined dude i love it
i don't know why you're so upset about
it there's no [ __ ] way this is
working dude i'm calling julissa
hello julissa i specifically paid the
four thousand dollars because i wanted
to see oil painting not some [ __ ]
you sent the practice one this is not
what i asked for this looks like i could
have done this [ __ ] in 10 minutes
myself what's going on with the beanies
on the kid's head i said i wanted a 30
stack
there's no way i can present this to the
family
it's so [ __ ] unprofessional looks
like a child's painting
my head might be double the size of
helos look at that you have a big head
no i don't have a big head look at this
the proportions are way off dude
her head plus his head isn't even as big
as my head
i specifically said just make me normal
size with the two of them i don't need
to be
a freakishly weird sized head and why am
i smoking with the bait
that's only seven beanies i asked for a
thirty beanie stack what the [ __ ]
is this dude no one's gonna laugh at
that that's not even funny
she [ __ ] this up so bad
i really like it i don't know why trying
is awesome i will say that you do have a
huge head though so
she wasn't our jalissa your brother
right now
you have a very big head as well ethan
well thank you very much
i'll say this you know i would like a
little bit of respect because i just
want you to know how much heart
i put into these presents and in return
what do i get
disrespect and that's the last time i'm
doing this show man
i've been i've been literally the best
guest you ever had who's came here
showered you with gifts and this is how
you repay me
that's true i do feel bad that we don't
have
johnny kids has [ __ ]
i mean this is my this is one of my
favorite gifts i love i love everything
about it
yeah that [ __ ] cost four thousand
dollars and that's my gift to you out of
my pocket
and what do i get dude nothing but
disrespect
love your music i love your videos i
think you're a great
well i don't think you're a great guy
but i do like your art i think you're a
shitty dude who makes good art
can you accept that as a compliment i
think you're a shitty dude
i mean that's a con that's nice i'm just
gonna pretend you didn't say anything
we'll just leave it at that how's that
you're a great guy oliver tree music
ugly is beautiful
out right now um the reviews are bad but
listen to it anyway how are the reviews
bad right the reviews are [ __ ]
incredible dude
everybody's saying this is the record
that she changed everything
not my review well yeah you know what if
you didn't make it through the second
song i don't want to hear your review to
be correct
no i listened to the whole album oh did
you how many songs was it again
12. 14.
14 you're right i was texting you know
what you
listen to it again sometime you know i
think you'd enjoy it maybe i don't know
what kind of music do you listen to
oliver what i want to apologize to you
thank you because i as good as an
interviewer and a journalist
as i am i was unable to squeeze even an
ounce of interesting juice
out of a [ __ ] total bad lemon
you ever get a lemon out of your garden
that's just it looks good from the
outside but the minute you squeeze it
it's just
bone dry sauce yeah your face looks like
a big scrunched up lemon
and i squeeze why was that so funny why
is my own produce feeling that
it was funny why is hell yeah
[ __ ]
who wins this game yo you're just the
driest lemon bro
and i squeeze and i'm like and like i'm
a guy who knows how to squeeze fruit you
know what i'm saying
and i squeeze that nothing more than a
[ __ ] dell pickle just
just end it i get a couple of drips
that's all i get from you
so i am sorry all i gotta say nathan is
that i got the best
jacket in the whole world out of this
thank you so much yeah that's good for
me yeah
cool cool i got it i got a baby
a business card show your gift i got a
business card
it says here here oliver would you ever
sell these
is that the plan um honestly i just want
to give them to really special people at
this point
you know i wouldn't even consider it
it's just for people who i you know look
up to and especially
fashion people and people who are in
that world you know and if you ever need
a designer
if you ever need anybody to come over
and maybe potentially do any designs for
the teddy fresh company you let me know
i can do it via distance
snail mail you let me know i have all
kinds of designs i'd love to send them
okay
we do have an intern opening
it's unpaid by the way is it a paid
internship or
unpaid is it paid or not i'm paid bro
i'll have to get back to i need to talk
to my business manager about that
but i think i don't think there's a way
to minimum wage
what'd you say minimum wage can you hear
us because the internet's dropping out
yeah at this point anything would be
better than what the label is paying me
yeah you know what oliver
i love you you are a talent you are a
powerhouse you are a true original
you are a tour you are a tour de
force is that the expression good luck i
mean i wish you lots of success i hope
everybody in the world listens to your
album i hope it gets a billion i hope
your music videos
get each a billion views i wish that for
you thank you man
and i hope that you'll fi truly be
satisfied with knowing that
you are the tour de france
thank you man and i know i'll never be
satisfied so i'm just going to learn to
love and accept myself
and except where i'm at and at this
point i'm going to go do something
productive with my day i'll see you guys
later
can someone pull me out of here all
right we'll see you later buddy
see you guys later [ __ ] the [ __ ]
brakes jammed
all right man take care
hurry up see you guys later yeah see you
later buddy jesus
okay oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no no no no no
no
the [ __ ] thing dude what the [ __ ] all
right see you guys later
care of y'all what are you guys doing
what the [ __ ] are you doing
why are you wearing your outfits
what see you guys
that ass later you better watch out
[Music]